I have no problem with you like she said
girls don't care I have no problem with
you doing whatever you want to do
because like you said you're being
honest about it I also have no problem
with you deciding that when you come to
settle down that you want somebody with
a low body count
what I have a problem with is all the
modern women out there that are sleeping
with men like you and they can't accept
that men like you want a woman with a
low body count Auntie that's what I
always say like you look perfect you
know your buff your tanned you're young
you're handsome you're driven and any
woman will have you but what they don't
understand is that you don't want any
woman you want a woman for today you
don't want a woman for forever and you